[Music]
the Pedic 175 anniversary sale in the
175 years of this history the most
amazing array of time pieces has been
made this particular sale shows a breath
that has never been seen
before we have the Sam Sorenson
perpetual calendar pocket watch who was
Sam Sorenson he was a gentleman who
managed a mine in South America and he
managed it so well the miners that
worked for him went to Tiffany they
chose this watch and they even had it
monogrammed in the back it has a hidden
hinge and only the finest Tech
casemakers were ever able to make this
type of
construction we have a reference 530 in
steel from
1939 this is the very first 530 in steel
ever made there are only nine known
Steel 530s in existence today many would
assume that a steel watch would be worth
less than a Golder plattinum watch
that's not always true in the world of
PCH the Boeing reference 130 Split
Second chronograph this was the personal
watch that belonged to William E Boeing
the founder of Boeing
Airlines why does it have on the minute
hand three red stripes the early
branding of the Boeing Company was three
red stripes and this may have been a way
for him to honor all of his success in
the business world it's a split second
single button chronograph only nine
known in a round case my favorite part
about it is above 6:00 a cardier sub
signature yellow gold reference
1563 Split Second water resistant
chronograph with a pulse meter dial alt
together this piece represents something
that's uh quite special indeed there are
three 1563 is ever made this piece is
the ultimate trophy for the leading
collections in the
world the perpetual calendar chronograph
in 1941 pek phip introduced to the world
the first wrist Perpetual chronograph
there's only a handful made in rose gold
in fact only four are known to the
market and this is one of the four and
arguably the one in the best condition
it hasn't been refinished and it hasn't
been modified in any way since the day
it was
[Music]
born